[Music]
welcome to the royal observatory of
edinburgh virtual world and what i'm
going to be doing is using uh stellarium
to guide us around
and some of the stars that you'll be
able to see in the summer skies i've
decided that tonight we're going to
focus on just the things that we're
going to be able to see with our own
eyes
and because not everyone has telescopes
but there's still lots of really awesome
things out there and for those of you
who know edinburgh the royal observatory
is on blackfoot hill and you can see the
view here out on our rooftop um and you
can see arthur's seat and also um
edinburgh castle so um let's advance
time and see our sun set
um and we'll see what stars are going to
come out in our night sky
and so the first stars i want to show
you are the um sort of most obvious
things in the summer sky
and we call this the summer triangle
uh vega deneb and altair now and you'll
be able to find them because they are
literally the brightest stars in the
night sky in the summer so all you need
to do is to go out there it doesn't
matter if you're in a in a bright urban
location you will still see the summer
triangle
and i'm going to tell you some cool
facts about the summer triangle because
i think when we look up at the stars
it's
really important to
rethink where that light comes from so
let's start with vega and now vega is
a sun it's about the tenth of the age of
our own sun um it's really interesting
vega because it's got a disc of dust um
around it where planets are forming
could well be life forming around vega
um now the light
uh from vega is created in a very hot
burning ball of gas it is a fusion
reaction happening in the core between
hydrogen and helium and once that's
light's been created in the core of vega
it takes 25 years for it to travel
across the galaxy um towards us on earth
so when you look up at vega i want you
to think about what you were doing 25
years ago when that light left vega and
i'm a little bit embarrassed to say that
i was um dancing in my room to spice
girls i'll tell you what i want what i
really really want because
the spice girls released their debut uh
single 25 years ago when that light uh
left vega so uh i wonder what you guys
were doing um 25 years ago that's vega
top of the summer triangle up here um
now uh let's think about altair um down
here now um the light from altair hasn't
traveled for quite as long as the light
from vega only 17 years it's taken the
light for us to uh reach us from altair
um i don't know what you guys were doing
17 years ago but it was the first
episode of strictly come dancing uh
broadcasted on bbc um and also the birth
of facebook i know a lot of us think
facebook's been around for a long time
but uh when you look up at altair that
light left when facebook didn't even
exist um now what's interesting about
altair is uh it's it's giving itself a
bit of a headache um now
vega is is quite like our own sun um our
sun is a um a sphere much like this this
basketball and it takes about a month uh
to fully rotate around and now auto is
very different um from our own sun and
vega in that it's spinning really really
fast and it only takes nine hours for
altair to do one full rotation so
actually ends up looking
like a rugby ball okay so when you look
up at altair i want you to imagine think
about that burning ball of gas that's
spinning so fast it's giving itself a
crazy headache and flattening down to
look like
a rugby ball
let's move on to the third star in the
summer triangle deneb over here now
when we look at vega and also we can
imagine what we were doing or we can
remember what we were doing 25 and 17
years ago
now deneb the light from deneb that
we're seeing today it left deneb when
nebuchadnezzar was being crowned king of
babylon yes when he started building his
hanging gardens of babylon that is how
long it's taken the light to reach us
from deneb 2
and sixteen years and what's interesting
when you look up at the summer triangle
you'll see that den and vega and also
all look about the same brightness and
now i want you to imagine that you are
very rich and have a really big garden
wouldn't it be lovely to have a really
big garden okay so you are uh in your
garden and you're gonna send someone off
walking down your garden backing away
from you and they're holding a torch all
right and so when they're close to you
that torch will look bright and when
they're further away that torch will
look uh much dimmer and you'll be able
to guess how far down the garden they
are by how bright the torch light looks
the fact that we see denim vega and
altair to be the same brightness even
though dinner is much much much much
much further away it's taken 2
616 years for that light to reach us
that tells us that deneb is a really
super super bright
star
much much brighter than our own sun and
vega and altair it is 200
000 times brighter than our own sun if
deneb was here in our own solar system
it would be so fat it would come all the
way out to the orbit of earth that is
how monstrous deneb is so
go out
find the summer triangle
think of vega and the spice girls
altaren's spinning headache deneb the
hanging gardens of babylon and a really
fat star that's 200 times larger than
our own sun and i want you to just
marvel at that gorgeous summer triangle
so uh what you're seeing now
have set stellarium to give us the the
type of night sky that we would
typically see in an urban location
um now in scotland where i am we are
incredibly lucky that the most of
scotland even though most of us don't
live in these regions but a lot of
scotland has incredibly incredibly dark
skies
um scotland has two internationally
recognized dark skies one in the
cairngorms and one in the galloway and
these are internationally recognized as
places where there is no light pollution
um so what i'm going to do now is turn
off the light pollution in edinburgh
with the power of stellarium and you'll
see what
we can see
suddenly zing all of these stars appear
out of the night sky and you can see
passing between vega and altar in that
summer triangle so if you draw a line
from dinner to the middle of fager and
altair you see all of this
light in between and that is our milky
way galaxy
if you're lucky enough to get into one
of these international dark sky parks
and you're lucky enough for the scottish
weather to clear not always a given
then you can see this milky way galaxy
with your own eyes now let me try and
explain what's going on here i have
created a galaxy in my living room out
of a plate
here we are
this is uh my model of the milky way
galaxy and so this is our um we don't
know really what our milky way galaxy
looks like because we haven't sent
anything out of our milky way galaxy but
we think it it's a spiral galaxy um like
this galaxy here
now when uh our milky way galaxy formed
it was spinning so um you know i was
talking about how altair was spinning
and ended up looking like a rugby ball
it's the same with our galaxy it spun so
much that it ends up as a a disc okay so
our galaxy our own milky way galaxy
isn't like a a sphere it's actually disc
like like this and it's spinning around
now at the center of a milk away galaxy
is a massive super massive black hole
and you have all of these stars swirling
around it and there are
if you uh if you want to know there are
at least three or four stars
per human being on planet earth okay so
there are seven billion humans on planet
earth each one of those humans gets to
pick three or four um stars in the milky
way to make up all of the stars in the
milky galaxy there are huge numbers of
them now why do we see the milky way
galaxy as a stripe across the sky
passing through denim between vega and
old set well it's because
our milky way is a disc so um here i am
my little observer here and i'm going to
um put my observer in the galaxy roughly
where we are
in the milky way galaxy and so uh we are
sort of halfway in between uh the center
of our galaxy and out uh if we wanted to
travel all the way to the black hole at
the center of our milky way galaxy it
would take us 200 uh no 26 000 light
years so a pretty long distance all
right now um okay so here i am my
observer on the disc now if i look up or
if i look down i don't see very many
stars um because my galaxy is a disc but
if i look out along the disk
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas